ce que vous imaginez les gens me
demandent souvent ce que je fais comme
travail puis que je réponde
informaticiens développeurs programmeurs
j'ai toujours un peu l'impression que
les gens s'imaginent que je tape sur un
écran noir avec les écritures verte fixa
déficit pas rapidement vu qu'on n'a pas
le temps de les mais dans les faits
c'est pas ça du tout mais leur prochaine
question un peu j'imagine que les gens
pensent un peu que je sais c'est donc la
prochaine question c'est mais qu'est ce
que tu fais dans le quotidien que si tu
es dans ton d'études et au travail
puis j'ai beaucoup pensé à 7
à cette question la france a la réponse
puis la meilleure réponse que j'ai pu
trouver c'est que les développeurs à
créer des outils donc vous connaîtrez
susi surnom de logiciels donc ce que ce
soit pour la communication
l'apprentissage la recherche
fondamentale les sites web que vous
fréquentez de temps à autre ou même vos
téléphones intelligents 1
on sait on trouve des logiciels à la
base de tout ça donc c'est ça notre
travail et donc quand arrive le temps de
choisir quelque chose à faire à l'école
en carrière vous reconnaîtrez les autres
domaines assez vide en biologie et
physique mathématique architecture
médecine un l'informatique s'est senti
son domaine à parents donc on peut c'est
un domaine comme les autres bref on peut
étudier ça au cégep l'on peut utiliser
ces universités 1 puis le but de ma
présentation aujourd'hui c'est de vous
convaincre que non seulement
informatique si les normes et
d'informatique dans toutes les autres
de plus en plus c'est une réalité de nos
jours que l'informatique s'incruste dans
la plupart des flux par des domaines
un exemple que je peux l'exemple le plus
frappant c'est la biologie maintenant
les écoles offrent des programmes
bio informatique par exemple ou de
biologie computationnelle on peut
retrouver sam et guile fils est venu du
nu de la réalisation que la biologiste
ça devenait un peu trop complexe surtout
notre séquence de l'adn assez compliqué
qu'il fallait qu'ils impliquent des
logiciels fallait qu'ils impliquent
l'informatique dans tout ça
donc ils ont créé des champagnes ont
créé des disciplines qu'on peut
s'inscrire maintenant universités donc
la bio informatique ou autre donc
aujourd'hui j'espère vous convaincre que
j'ai choisi quelques exemples ciblés
dans quel nom plusieurs domaines aussi
de vous convaincre que non seulement
informatique c'est quelque chose à part
mais l'informatique ce qu'on fait dans
notre travail c'est beaucoup de
s'associer à d'autres disciplines
puis vraiment essayé de révolutionner
plusieurs autres disciplines
puis j'ai fermement l'impression que les
prochaines révolutions les prochaines
les inventions nouvelles technologies
qui vont arriver ça va être à
l'intersection discipline qui existent
déjà comme la médecine ou larchitecture
puis l'informatique
donc je voudrais commencer par le
transport donc à la base le transport si
on ceci en recul me tombe 20 30 ans le
transport c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
une histoire d'ingénieur mécanique donc
l'histoire de construire quelque chose
qui va vous amener du point a au point b
et donc de la mécanique la taille des
matériaux il ya deux châssis à
construire donc il faut le but dans le
fond c'est de créer une voiture
confortable sécuritaire efficace et tout
ça c'était train c'était vraiment un
problème mécanique qui avait pas va pas
vraiment de l'électronique les ceux qui
se souviennent des voitures des années
70 pas vraiment d'électronique là dedans
même pas du tout puis donc avec avec les
années entre le temps en améliorant les
les processus les matériaux les les
design de voitures et ont réussi à faire
des autos plus rigide plus sécuritaires
tout ça mais éventuellement ils sont
rendus compte que pour améliorer
sécurité dans les transports il faudrait
qu'ils amènent des nouvelles
technologies donc qu'est-ce qu'on a eu
au début
en fait qu'est-ce qu'on a eu beaucoup
plus tard mais ça va commencer
tranquillement avec les coussins
gonflables et tout ça mais
éventuellement ce qu'ont eu ces des
technologies assez poussées qui
maintenant font que font les gens sont
plus en sécurité
ces deux technologies le la première à
gauche c'est la vision nocturne donc un
écran 1 on peut voir les personnes sur
la route donc ces deux technologies sont
venus à la à cause d'une réalisation que
pour augmenter la sécurité il fallait
non seulement améliorer la structure de
la voiture améliorée le châssis ou quoi
le même les matériaux mais il fait
vraiment le facteur humain qui causait
la plupart des accidents donc les gens
étaient fatigués les gens avaient manqué
d'expérience puis silence de la grande
cause d'accidents c'était les gens les
humains au volant dans le fond le
conducteur est donc lieu la technologie
à gauche dans certaines voitures de luxe
maintenant à la vision de nuit puis un
autre technologie un peu plus
intéressante à celle espèce de radar
adaptatif le l'espèce de le contrôler ou
votre voiture peut même voir voir devant
puis si un ralentissement à petit elle
réagit avant l'humain donc elle peut
anticiper les collisions 1
donc c'est une technologie technologie
fantastique puis quand vous pensez qu'on
voit maintenant sans qu'ils à 100 km
heure puis arrive quelque chose en avant
le temps conclut mme veilleux ça peut
faire la différence entre un accident
fait pas d'accident du clignement d'yeux
c'est quand même quelques mètres le
plusieurs mètres en fait lorsque
lorsqu'on roule à une vitesse comme ça
donc ils ont inventé ces technologies là
c'est disponible sur certaines voitures
l'espèce deux espèces de radars de
comédiens cruise control adaptatif puis
les assistance au conducteur
mais les chercheurs sont dit mais si on
vous doit encore améliorer la sécurité
réduire les morts sur les routes
faudrait carrément est ce qu'on risque
ont présenté quelque chose qui
enlèverait carrément le facteur humain
dans dans le transport donc ils se sont
mis à la tâche
puis ça a commencé vers une dizaine
d'années environ en 2005
c'est un challenge qui était un défi qui
a été créée par le gouvernement
américain et appelait le dup green
challenge donc le gouvernement donne il
défie essayé universitaires et autres
équipes essayer de construire un
véhicule qui peut un conduire tout seul
sans conducteur du tout donc
complètement autonome si vous regardez
sur la photo je peux vous voyez bien
mais un peu de conducteurs en tout et
même un gros collants dans le pare brise
donc une voiture complètement autonome
le plein de caméras plaindra d'or sur
sur la voiture puis ça c'est cet exemple
c'est la voiture qu'elle gagne en 2005
pour la première fois ça faisait
quelques années qu'ils roulaient le défi
mais n'avait jamais aucune voiture qui
avait gagné puissant vraiment un
parcours difficile dans le désert on
peut peut-être regarder ses vidéos
pendant sept heures 7 heures de temps la
voiture folle est qu'à parcours de façon
autonome n'y avait pas de télécommande
n'y avait personne
c'était juste un ordinateur un puits et
donc à devait devaient parcourir un
parcours quand même assez compliqué il y
en a quelques-unes qu'ils ont terminée
mais eux l'équipe de stanford en
californie
donc dans ces contes va lyon ils ont
réussi à remporter le défi
puis vous voyez toutes les caméras se
dessus il y avait probablement plein
ordinateur à l'intérieur donc c'est
quand même assez complexe parce qu'une
voiture qui évalue son environnement ne
s'était pas il fallait qu'elle évalue
toutes les potentiels obstacles donc les
rushs etc puis donc sa séquence quand la
terminer après 7 heures une grogne un
prix de 2 millions de dollars si ce
texte est quand même
intégrant un accomplissement puis depuis
ce temps là à chaque année comme unis
améliorent le le défi qui roulait encore
de nos jours
lens 8 les années suivantes il était
dans dix espèces de petites villes
c'était quand même des circuits fermés
mais ces défauts ce vil donc essayer
d'améliorer la technologie pour voir où
est ce qu'on peut se rendre justement
avec avec une voiture qui se conduit
toute seule puis maintenant où est-ce
qu'on est rendu aujourd'hui en 2015 peut
être que vous le demander on est rendu à
des voitures qui se conduisent toute
seules sur la route donc sur sur nos
routes
peut-être entendu parler mais à
plusieurs équipes mieux donc les toutes
les universités qui travaillaient sur le
challenge que j'ai mentionnés ont
continué d'innover puis maintenant en
2015 c'est là qu'on est rendu
donc si vous voulez voir si vous voyez
ça c'est qu'est ce que la voiture voix
dans sa tête
si on peut appeler ça comme ça mais vous
voyez si vous regardez la vidéo qui a
détecte les constructions dont il ya des
tacles et qu'on détecte des cyclistes à
détecter les autres voitures puis à peut
conduire de façon totalement autonome
donc d'outremont je dirais à maintenir
d'ici à québec que pourrait naviguer
comme comme un humain pourrait le faire
donc si un cycliste un geste qui va
tourner à gauche d'un loto comme
reconnaît ça je te reconnais la lune les
lumières de circulation à cause keller
plusieurs plusieurs caméras plusieurs ce
radar etc
donc c'est là qu'on est rendu puis
l'idée derrière seul c'est pas seulement
pour pour essayer de faire la science
fiction une réalité mais l'idée derrière
ça c'est c'est la sécurité comme je vous
disais donc est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
peut remplacer l'humain qui est le grand
facteur d accidents par
un ordinateur puis leur hypothèse c'est
prouvé c'est prouvé avéré un parce que
cette voiture en font des tests depuis
les millions de kilomètres dont qui
conduisent des millions de kilomètres
pions n'y a pas encore eu d'accident
grave donc ses meilleurs qu'à nîmes 1-2
de beaucoup donc on peut imaginer si ça
s'en vient dans quelques années ils
parlent d'environ 2,50
c'est quand même ça sent bien quand même
assez rapidement les voitures qui se
conduisent toute seules donc vous seriez
à bord de votre voiture puis pendant que
le taux se conduit toute seule je vais
faire autre chose donc ça c'est un autre
bénéfice faux texte et pas besoin
d'attendre
pas besoin d'attendre la halte texto
pour aller texter mais aussi pas besoin
non plus d'avoir des stationnements
proche de nos building parce que le taux
peut juste neuf portés à porte puis à
l'iscom ce parc est un peu plus loin
donc si ces désavantages on pense pas
c'est immédiatement mais ça peut
potentiellement régler beaucoup de
problèmes qu on trafique tu donc voici
comment l'informatique c'est comme
incrustée dans le domaine du transport
dès le début on n'avait pas vraiment
mais là avec les systèmes de sécurité
avec on est rendus on est maintenant on
en est rendu là on est on va déjà penser
silence l'ordinateur pouvait remplacer
carrément le conducteur ceci est un
exemple donc l'informatique amène une
mènent une révolution un peu dans le
domaine qui était purement mécanique
avant donc pour l'informatique
les gens qui créent des voitures
maintenant les différentes compagnies
ont pas le choix d'être au courant des
dernières technologies pas le choix
d'avoir des gens formés à utiliser les
logiciels qui sont disponibles donc le
deuxième le deuxième domaine que je
voulais discuter c'est la santé le
bien-être
puis c'est facile de voir un peu comment
la technologie c
s'est amené dans les siens dans la santé
donc on prend un rendez vous chez le
médecin ou le tout et tout est
d'informatiser maintenant on peut
recevoir un message pour le rendez vous
on peut les dossiers sont informatisées
les instruments sont de plus en plus
technologique 1
mais moi je voulais vous parler plus
d'un autre aspect qui est des
révolutions un peu des émotions dans la
santé qui répondent été possible si ray
pas eu la technologie
donc j'ai quelques exemples 1 une
application qui s'appelle buman eyes
donc si quelqu'un qui a eu l'idée très
simple d'ailleurs mais qui était rendue
possible grâce aux téléphones
intelligents de prendre une personne
n'attend une personne aveugle et les
problèmes de vision qui a besoin des
deux par exemple si dans dans l'exemple
d'un hasard à lire sur la peine de lire
la date d'expiration quoi que ce soit
donc en prenant son téléphone peut
envoyer un message à une personne
bénévole à droite ici qui peut aider à
analyser l'image ou analyser les vidéos
pour dire qu'est-ce qui se passe donc
encore une fois quelque chose qu'elle
n'a pas vraiment été dit ce possible de
faire sans la technologie
la deuxième personne la deuxième
personne d'une personne daltonienne
c'est quelqu'un que présentée à tête
vous fait de l'écouté
c'est très bon d'ailleurs présenté à
têtes bleues de ce peut-être quelques
années puis sept personnels daltonienne
donc daltonienne complète voix seulement
noir et blanc donc
donc c'est un problème pour cette
personne là avec en collaboration avec
des chercheurs en informatique a réussi
à se concocter va l'expliquer d'ailleurs
je veux passer les vidéos réussi à
concocter une caméra un parent du par
dessus la tête qui est capable de pour
lui traduire les couleurs en sont des
textes
d'accord pour commencer une fin 2006
shipping co écrit de colin normalement
capable de violer même chose avec la vie
va être capable de faire la même chose
avec sorry je les coupe éventuellement
mais ça qui avait pas vraiment utiliser
sa caméra cette journée là pour
s'habiller mais mais c'est devenu comme
une deuxième nature pour cette personne
n'a comme à chaque jour il pense même
plus ils voient les interprètes les
couleurs comme si comme s'ils voyaient
comme si vous voyez que de la même façon
nous donc pourquoi ça peut être
important pour cette personne-là de
comme essayer de remédiation ces
handicaps avec une caméra comme ça c'est
que par exemple est en train de essayer
de voir pourquoi son internet marche pas
il regarde regarde la machine bon il se
fait dire il faut que la lumière verte
eut allumé n'est pas la jaune ou qu'ils
aient des trucs comme ça donc c'est
vraiment un cas où la couleur c'est
important puis il ya les par exemple les
médicaments de nuit et pas de nuit lundi
sur l'acquis la somnolence et tout donc
souvent ces deux couleurs du ferme donc
ça devient des exemples comme sont
bénins mais pour cette personne-là avoir
une caméra comme ça qui a fait en
collaboration avec des chercheurs en
informatique
ça devient franchement intéressant
ensuite on tombe un peu dans la science
fiction ça c'est une lentille lentilles
de contact qui permet pour les
diabétiques de mesurer leur niveau de
glucose dans le sang donc les gens ce
médecin dans l'oeil un puits si vous
regardez mans est un circuit
électronique donc circuits électroniques
sur la lentille de contact
les gens s'y met ça dans l'oeil puis sa
mesure le niveau de glucose par les
larmes
pas s'inquiéter au besoin de couleurs il
mais ça envoie
salut glucose de façon régulière
puissant voici un téléphone intelligent
ensuite la personne peut le voir ou
l'envoyer à son médecin ou quoi que ce
soit donc ça c'est vraiment un comédien
un exemple entre la biologie puis
l'informatique puis la chimie d'une
certaine façon
puis génie électrique donc les bénéfices
sont claires on pas besoin de faire le
test ou est-ce qu'on doit se piquer
s'extraire du sang puis c'est peut-être
déjà c'est un prototype donc ça marche
mais c'est dans quelques années donc
c'est possiblement voir ce bientôt
puis pour revenir plus dans la réalité
un comment la technologie peut amener
des impacts vraiment réel ça c'est pour
une population en afrique faut savoir
que la grande partie de la population en
afrique on on plus accès à un téléphone
mobile qu'est l'électricité
donc ces 39% accès à un téléphone
cellulaire contre 32% qui ont accès à
l'électricité
peut-être que certains diront comment
ils font pour recharger leurs téléphones
mais c'est qui on sait qu'ils aiment
tant il ya lyon de téléphones
cellulaires ils peuvent aller le charger
au village puis ensuite le ramener chez
eux dans leur maison qui a peut-être les
restait donc comment ça peut changer
leur l'orateur d'avoir un téléphone
mobile d'avoir des technologies à leur
portée c'est que ils peuvent recevoir
des messages comme sa droite ici ses
marques et qui va avoir une instruction
de bientôt donc ça ça les affecte dans
leur vie quotidienne
puis la femme à gauche peut par exemple
regarder des informations sur sa
grossesse puis des études qui ont
démontré que c'est vraiment un problème
en afrique parce que les gens manquent
d'information sur la santé sur leur
santé puis ont peu tendance à aller se
faire soigner en plus tendance à s'auto
diagnostiquer puis à se fier à leur
instinct
donc ça c'est un gros problème mais avec
39% de la population qui avec son
téléphone cellulaire
on peut les informer
on peut d informer d'une meilleure façon
je suis donc ils peuvent eux mêmes c'est
d'améliorer leur sens donc c'est le
c'était le résumé donc j'espère que je
vous ai fait réaliser que l'informatique
s'est pas seulement l'écran l'écran noir
avec les écritures verte mais c'est
beaucoup aussi des impacts comme dans
les milieux comme le transport comme la
santé puis ça vaut la peine de
promouvoir l'informatique tout ça à
travers non seulement son propre domaine
d'études
mais en faisant partie d autres d autres
disciplines donc c'est important à la
base de savoir comment se servir des
technologies parce que c'est maintenant
ça laissait entrer dans tout dans tous
les domaines l'info puis en espérant
vous en avoir appris plus il ya main sur
mon travail à tous les jours merci